German.
I can't wait. Don't
Yeah, we're good.
>> All right. Welcome to the January 14th,
2026 full board meeting of Manhattan
Community Board 6. My name is Sandy McKe
and I'm the chair of CB6. This meeting
is called to order at 7:02 p.m. And
tonight we are joined by First Vice
Chair John Keller, Secretary Jerry
Weinstein, District Manager Jesus Perez,
and Assistant District Manager Brennan
Bur. As a reminder, New York State law
requires all community board members who
are not able to attend the meeting in
person have their cameras on and their
first and last names displayed from the
time the meeting is called to order
until the time the meeting is adjourned.
Ground rules, do not speak until granted
the floor. Please raise your hand and
wait for me to recognize you. It is
important that only one person speaks at
a time so that members of the public
watching at home can understand what is
being said. You will be given a
microphone if you are recognized to
speak. The chat function should not be
used for CB6 business or questions about
agenda topics. Members of the public, if
you wish to give remarks during the
public session and have not already
registered by filling out a form, you
can register to speak in the public
session on Zoom by using the Q&A feature
and posting your name, your affiliation,
and what specific topic you wish to
speak about. Or if you're here in person
and want to speak in the public session,
you need to fill out our public speaker
form which is near the signins for the
CB6 newsletter. This needs to be done by
7:15.
The night the agenda for tonight's
meeting was distributed ahead of time by
the board office was posted online and
appears on the screen before you. If
there's no objection, we will adopt the
agenda as stated. Board members, if you
object to adopt the agenda, you may
raise your hand.
Seeing no objections, the agenda for
tonight's meeting is adopted. Jerry will
now take attendance by Warhol.
>> Howdy folks. Happy New Year.
>> Tanya
>> here.
>> Present
Barklay
>> Elvie Barroso.
>> Daniel Bernstein present.
Liz Burr present.
>> Jim Collins
>> absent.
>> Stuart Desert
>> here.
>> Beatatric Disman
>> present.
>> Maya Donaf.
>> Robert Faran
>> present.
Friedman.
Jason from
>> Eric Goldberg.
Eric Goldberg.
>> Yeah. Stand Justin
Gloria. Hey,
>> Rabia.
>> Rabia
>> Paige. Judge
>> Paige
Rupal
>> here. Don
>> present.
>> Kate
>> absent.
>> Katie Landon
>> present.
>> Sandre Liftoff
>> here.
>> Anton
>> Sandra
>> here.
>> Alec
>> present.
>> Richard Mintz.
>> Kevin O'Keefe.
Kevin O'Keema
>> here.
>> Steven Curtis,
>> present.
>> Will Perry present.
Mariam
absent.
Larry Sher.
Larry Sherb
an Sullivan
>> present.
>> Sandro Sherrod
>> Sadik
>> present.
>> Letty Simon
>> Samir Badar.
>> Mark Thompson
>> present. Hey Mark,
Gabe Tzo,
>> Cat Valero,
>> James Vera,
>> myself Weinstein, Sarah Whittington,
>> David Woods,
>> absent.
>> Shuya Xiao,
>> present.
>> You'll tell me how to pronounce that
properly later. This concludes
>> all right with 36 members. Julie present
or you have no
>> All right. Our elected officials sent in
their reports ahead of time and they are
compiled on the CB6 website. The links
to the the link to the reports was sent
out ahead of time for your convenience
and can be found in the chat on Zoom or
by going to our website's page for full
board meetings. I will call in each of
the elected officials who have RSVPd so
they can take questions from CB6 members
and the public with um about their
reports. Each elected official will be
able to field questions. If there are no
questions, we will move on to our next
official on our list. Um if there's a
time-sensitive matter, they will uh
report that didn't make it into their
presubmitted their report, they will do
so. We have the honor of having our new
burough president, Bradman Hoyman
Seagull, with us this evening.
Thank you. Thank you. Good to see
everyone. Thank you very much. Hello,
Jerry. I text
Brad Eagles. Good to see everyone. Uh
your 28th Manhattanboro president and
I'm happy to be here to welcome everyone
to the new year uh to my new year uh and
give you a short report. First, I want
to introduce a couple of colleagues who
are here. Uh we have a new director of
community affairs, Marielle Ali, who is
here. Say hello to Marielle.
>> Hello.
>> And everyone knows the amazing Vera
Rosenberg who's been our amaz. So say
hello.
>> Um the first and biggest news is that
community board applications
begin in earnest. They will start and go
live this Friday, January 16th. uh
that'll be due at the end of February,
February 27th. So, um look for that.
We'll make sure that you get the link
and the application is very similar to
the past, but um we'll help walk you
through the process if any current or
prospective board members have
questions. Uh secondly, we're planning
um an inauguration celebration and more
important than that, a burough
convention. It's our vision to gather uh
community [clears throat] boards and
other stakeholders together on February
22nd. That's a Sunday. Uh from 1 to 4:00
p.m. It's going to be at Alice Tony Hall
at Lincoln Center. That's Broadway and
65th Street. There's some little flags
in the back, but [clears throat]
it's going to be
collective community agenda setting
meeting. uh you know with the big postit
notepads facilitators and an opportunity
for uh people to let the new Manhattan
president office know about what's on
their mind and what they want to see us
address. So I think it's an earnest
attempt to really rely on our community
partners to help drive the agenda out of
office. So that's the way I see it and I
welcome everyone to participate in that.
And then finally just wanted to say that
um we've uh filled out a number of
positions in our office and we'll be
making announcements soon for deputy
president and other posts including
director of land use and planning which
is a very important officer. So look
forward [clears throat] to working with
each and every one of you moving forward
and um happy new year again. Thank you
so much.
>> Do we have time for any questions?
>> I have a weird echo here. I don't really
talk to any.
>> So, as I'm sure you know, the city
charter uh charges the uh the executive
department.
you're supposed to provide information
when we have to for it. Um the reality
isn't quite so pretty. Um we have been
asked on several occasions to
departments even though we're a city
agency. Um so my first question is how
can your office help us get these
agencies to cooperate? And secondly, um,
many departments no longer like to pay
overtime. We meet in the evening. Many
of the people in those departments with
whom you want to speak only work during
the day. So they will not make them
available to us. So how can we address
that? Well, on the first question about
uh our council member Harvey Epstein is
here. I'd love to work with the council
member on perhaps a legislative response
to making certain that community boards
get the information they need and don't
have to resort to foil. That said,
please view my office working in
conjunction with council member epste as
leverage to get that information as
quickly as possible. Um, I know that
Marielle and Broa would be really
responsive to a community for request
um, in that regard as would I. So, let's
work in conjunction to get you
[clears throat] the information you need
and let's look at a legislative
potential
solution as well.
[laughter]
>> Yeah, already.
>> That's right. But in terms of requiring
you to foil, maybe we need um
clarification.
>> Okay, we're good at asking us.
[laughter]
>> Marty has a question.
as I've asked your predecessors for the
last 35 years.
>> The board after a few months
when the initial new members come in,
starts losing members by the end of the
term we're generally down 10.
And I've asked your predecessors
since you [clears throat] had this uh
dugout full of people who really want to
come on the board [clears throat] to
while there's a an a opening during the
year to get somebody on so that the
committees don't have to work with much
fewer [clears throat] people than we
really need.
>> Marty, we have a new member this
evening.
>> Okay.
>> That was just assigned to the board. But
I I completely agree that we have to
make quorum. Let's start with that. And
if it's hard to make quum because
members aren't being replaced and I
think it also goes to the initial
appointment process that we make sure we
appoint community members who are
committed to it and understand what
they're getting into. Um so there's a
couple of ways to approach that, but
certainly um being responsive to
vacancies I think is really important. I
take it seriously. I was a community
board member for a decade. I chair for
three years. Uh so I like
>> I know
and I hear on that. So let's make
certain that we are responsive to that.
Thank you.
>> Great. Hope any other questions. Well,
um I'm sure we'll think of something.
Thank you. See you soon. Thank you.
Um
Next we have our new council member
Harvey.
>> Want me over there? You want me
>> whatever you like
being over here. So I'm gonna come over
here.
>> Your hometown.
Want to thank our president Bradle.
I know his presence is going to be
missed in Albany. We'll be very very
lucky to have our president. Thank you.
But you went to Aldi yesterday. I didn't
go.
>> And just so you know that, you know,
community boards, I think you should be
really feel comfortable reaching out to
his office. It's going to be an ally. We
need to get replacements for our seats.
I know Brad's committed to that. He and
I both served on community boards very
long time. Both former chairs of board,
so we know how important community
boards are. And if you do have to figure
out this a legislative fix, it might
just be trying to get it directly from
the mayor's office and we try to push
that as well. So there way we can figure
that out together. Happy to. Um so I
want to introduce [clears throat] Ben.
Is this your first meeting?
>> Not yet.
>> Second meeting. Okay. I want to
introduce Ben from my team who's going
to be our community board six lon. Ben
is great. He really cares about this
community, cares for these issues. Reach
out to him in our newsletter. Everyone's
email. Um, it's in the back page of
newsletter. I think there's they're on
the back page. Yeah. So, if you need
your questions, we're all there.
Everyone's email. So, you can reach out
to all of us. So, you have questions.
Want to talk about things that are going
on in the last month. It feels like you
know when I was in the assembly I came
in doesn't feel that much different but
I'll just so I know earlier in the week
we had a rally trying to con I don't
know if people saw the con has proposed
you know increases again this year in
addition to the 25% increase they've got
in the last 5 years we had over 110
elected officials sign on to this letter
that we uh we sent to the public service
commission they're voting later this
month we're encouraging the mayor to
oppose this increase, you know, the idea
that, you know, people who are
struggling right now are struggling. And
my new colleague Virginia Maloney walked
in the door. [laughter]
>> He started rocking today. Virginia.
Um, so you know, Virginia and I were
were at this kind of press uh conference
and we're really hopeful that the mayor
along with other elected officials can
convince the governor and the public
service commission to oppose the
increase and review all we can do.
Really appreciate that. Um, also I don't
know if you heard earlier this week
staffer of the city council was um by
ICE who was at a press conference
earlier in the week with the speaker um
Julie Menon and yesterday we had a press
conference again with the the staff of
the the council. Um it rang just that
someone who's here legally, you know,
has working papers, works for the city
council, went for an appointment and was
detained even though they have a job.
They have connections here. It's really
just another outrageous what's happening
with ICE happened the other day on
Seventh Street just you know 10 minutes
from here. Someone's just picked up at
their place and employment. So what I
doing not just in New York but obviously
around the country is really really
despicable and it's you know I think we
it's really incumbent upon us to stand
up and speak out on these issues.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and we you know our inauguration
launch great things
youth council you can read it if you
want in the newsletter. Um yeah, had
some fun times because we got multist,
you know, if you haven't lost your tree
yet, you still want to do it, I
encourage you to do that. Um there's we
spent a little time um talking about you
the last couple weeks because you know
what the new mayor said is things we
talked about this be her program deal
with me pressures and where these holes
are and I think it's really important to
try to figure out how to fix those holes
in the system. I know Senator Gonzalez
and I have been talking a lot about
this. So, there's there's some really
important legislative fixes. If you
[clears throat] pay attention to
tomorrow, there'll be some announcements
on the city council, by the way, where
uh all the new members, all the
committee assignments, chair
assignments, all this stuff. So, that's
going to go public tomorrow. And if you
have questions, you know, please ask or
please ask Ben, my office. We want to
make sure we continue to be available
for this community. And if the chair
allows, I'll take a question,
>> please. Well, we've got three.
>> Tanya, do you want to go first?
>> Hi, Harvey. It's so great to see you.
Um, what is the justification? What are
they trying to explain as the increase,
the double digits increase on utilities?
Because oil is at $60 a barrel. I mean,
it's it's not like we're going through
an oil crisis. Is this the um AI centers
that's pushing this? What is it?
>> You know, it's interesting because we
haven't seen spikes in usage in New York
City, you know, and honestly 70% of uh
outside New York City uh
connectors
are to 9.4% profits. So like if they're
getting their shareholders 9.4% profits
of 150,000 New Yorkers last year the
utility shut off in the balance. I'd
rather get less profits and make sure
people keep their utilities on. You know
500,000 New Yorkers are behind. It's
just to me what we said is just really a
money grab by KED and I think we need to
stop them in their tracks. We talked a
lot about affordability. you know, it's
rent and utilities and that's what
affordability is about and I, you know,
kind of shouldn't be able to get away
with this.
>> How can we stop?
>> Well, we testify, we've written letters,
you encourage the mayor to support us. I
think that would be really helpful. The
board wants to pass resolutions and
their exec committee. You know, it's
really important to kind of fight this
increase and to stop the service
commission from allowing this to happen.
>> Thank you.
Ann and then Brook you had a question
too. You can just
>> since you mentioned Bernard a couple of
months ago we did pass a resolution in
support of it and expanding it but um
the earlier mayoral administration had
frozen it like no funding no expansion.
Are you saying that the new
administration is working on expanding
and how are they going to fund it? like
any do you have any other details?
>> Yeah, we talked to the mayor about this
and he's deeply committed to doing it
and moving towards a beard model and
creating a new 911 system which you know
allows people who need adult
professionals to get those people who
need social workers or the domestic
violence situation and people who need
police because of violence can get
different people to come out. So, it's
really restructuring 911. I've talked to
the may personally about it. is very
excited about doing it. I don't know the
time frame to do it, but my expectations
in in this year's budget, I think it'll
be a commitment from all of us.
>> Great. Ann has has a question.
>> Um, yeah, to just to follow up on
Tanya's question also, I mean, I don't
even buy I have to buy buy energy
distributed by K, [clears throat] but I
do not buy their energy, right? Right. I
use an ask and still they are like 60%
of the expense. It's it's crazy. So I
wonder if there are opportunities for
restructuring of that as well. And I did
not know about the
>> commitment to their shareholders. I feel
like damn I saw you.
>> You know we worked hard as you know in a
different hat when I was in worked hard
in trying to restructure kind of and the
public service commission and it was
really really hard to do because I
entrenched interest on the city level.
We really have little oversight over
kind so we can do [clears throat] what
we can but it you know and I think it's
is hard to do and kind basically has a
monopoly
>> right
>> which is why we should be able to
regulate them as a higher standard than
you know somebody that is operating in a
theoretically
>> and that's what the public service
commission was set up to do to regulate
them and as the understand uh increases.
>> My other question was actually about the
city council staffer that was detained
still detained.
>> Still detained.
He's originally from Venezuela. He was
steered legally. He, you know, worked
and said he was [clears throat] showing
up for a regular appointment. He's still
detained. And the message coming out of
the Trump administration is horrific.
Never no criminal history, no nothing.
And they're just saying we're keeping
him. is dangerous.
>> Don't show up for an appointment.
>> Right. That's the message. If you show
up going actually to 26 photo tomorrow
with a constituent who's got a 9:00 a.m.
appointment,
>> they have they're in a tough spot. They
either show up and potentially get
picked up or they don't show up and then
they risk getting picked up. There's no
winning.
>> So, I'm going to go with them tomorrow
morning at 9:00 a.m. because at least I
can put my body in front of theirs.
Awful.
Cert
has a question up here too.
>> You can have it. [laughter]
>> First of all, congratulations. And
switching gears a little bit. The mayor
and the governor together this week have
press conference or earlier what we call
child early childhood education. And I
was wondering whether any mechanisms
[clears throat]
for implementing that in its early days
have been identified and also wondering
whether there's room you know for a
community board to play. I know Dan
Garney and Ben Kalos are so active in
getting seats
>> for [clears throat] this the district
you know years ago. Is there any role
that the community board could play in
that?
>> I I think people know that you know 3K
and 3K is pretty up and running in our
neighborhood. So, it's really expanded
to it'll be the two case seats that
we're going to look to expand and
whatever the board can do to help um
support uh council member Money, myself,
Senator Gonzalez, you know, we'll have
an assembly member soon, not yet, but
you will um and force to make sure that
you know communities [clears throat]
across the city get heard. It's going to
be the state budget to be on how much
money we have and then we figure that
out how we're going to allocate it on
the city side. But I'm optimistic.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right, we have two more questions.
Maya would had her hand up and then and
then
>> um I had a question about what the
city's looking at as far as so we've
been asking about if the city docks are
upgrading them to be electrified so they
can get recharged at the station around.
Um so in relation to the company trying
to increase the price of energy how that
relates to they're trying to electrify
this become in this more
>> yeah I mean electrification and
increased energy cost you know some
really difficult thing because we need
more power because we're using more
electricity we're moving to more EV
vehicles we got
to put more charging infrastructure in
place we're also going to need that path
to plan ahead they increase their capac
capacity. Obviously, we had some browns
over the summer again this year. So,
it's a capacity issue that and I try to
name the client interview to hear about,
but they know this is our commitment and
they're the ones responsible putting,
you know, charging infrastructure in the
city. That's there's
given them that authority. So, they know
that they need to increase capacity and
increase load.
[clears throat]
>> Rashman, I think is our our last
question. I can hold up your
It's a great water bottle. Everyone that
>> Oh, and hand sanitizer.
[laughter]
>> To ask what John said this week, just I
think it was yesterday, a couple of
friends called me. They were trying to
get their children into KC and they
called me because they're like, "How do
we get in touch with the mayor's
office?" Apparently, there's a kiosk
where there's a QR code, sign up, we
have funding, but then when they go to
the website, the website's not working,
and then you're on hold for a couple of
hours when you try to call. Okay.
>> So, I told them to reach out to their
council member, and you were actually in
Virginia district. So, I put [laughter]
them in, but I just want to bring that
up.
>> Yeah, that's good. Virginia on the spot
when she
>> But yeah, that's if they have problems
with that, then we should be hearing it.
We can talk to you know they all we have
governmental contacts in the mayor's
office. We can be reaching out to them
directly to talk about the
>> addition easier to get in touch with the
council rather than the mayor's office.
>> Sure it's a little but true
>> right
>> you guys sponsor sponsor exactly on the
grounds. Thank you all for letting me
take so much your time and I hope
everyone has a good January and I'll see
you all soon. Thank you for coming.
>> And now we have council member Virginia
Maloney.
>> Thank you. I'm glad we had Barbie go
before me and all the tough questions.
I'm in the clear. But um I'm Virginia
Maloney and I'm really grateful to be
here as your council person to represent
District 4.
I'm a lifelong Manhattanite and grew up
on the east side of Manhattan and I'm
just very excited. So thank you for
having me here for my first community
board meeting as officially an elected
official.
Congratulations. I'm very lucky to get
to work with such great colleagues like
former assembly member, now council
member Barbie and we as mentioned have
already hit the ground running um
partnering on things that matter to this
community which where we share border
including the coned press conference
earlier this week or was it last it was
last week this week Monday. So all the
already bl together.
>> Yeah. So thank you again Harvey for
organizing that and for being here
tonight. I also want to take a moment to
recognize my predecessor Keith Powers
who was my council member for eight
years and we can give him
[clears throat] a round of applause. I'd
like to add
that he consistently showed up for
community board 6 and his offer
delivered real long-term results.
everything from tenants protection and
affordability advocacy to cutting
through red tape with agencies when
issues stall. Many of you got to work
with him directly and that kind of
follow through matters and being
available and accountable matters. So
I'm going to continue in that tradition
of public service over the next four
years and I'm grateful to call him a
friend and a confidant. We also had a
surprise visit in our new office this
week in Dan Robnik who came by to pick
up some artwork and share some stage
advice to to our team. Um so we've had
phenomenal examples of public servants
that have represented this district and
I hope to meet that same bar. Uh we kind
of heard a bit about what's been going
on in the council, but it's uh not been
a slow two weeks. I'm on day 14 on the
job. Um but we already stood up to
rising utility rates. Um I was at the
state of the state yesterday where I
heard from the governor about her
priorities and how those will impact the
city. everything from affordability,
which we all know is really top of mind
for New Yorkers, to AI policy that she's
planning to roll out at the state level
to protect um protect people and also be
just be more transparent when AI is
being used particularly in the case of
political ads. Um, let's see. We had a
briefing from the Spark Life Sciences to
learn more about that project and I know
you all will be invited to attend the
briefing on the 21st. Um, and we've had
two tenants association meetings. So,
both with Stason Peter Grouper Village,
and I was in this room just last night
at this same time talking to the
Wateride tenants. Um, so it's been a
busy busy few weeks, two weeks. Um, but
we are just getting started. The most
important update is that our office is
open. So, I want you all to know that we
are keeping Keith Powers's office for
the near term. So, you'll know where to
find us if you've been there before. And
it's the same building, right?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. I'm on the 12th floor. Um, so it
still says keep powers on the door, but
we're working we're working on changing
that. But, um, I will be there and I
want to take a minute to introduce our
team. So, Isabella,
>> hi everyone. My name is Isabella Sano.
I'll be working in constituent services
and in community affairs for the office.
Um, I'm an east side resident. Um, I'm
also an attorney, soon to be public. Uh,
so we're going to invite you into our
office for any of your notary public
needs.
So, moving forward, either I will be
here or a member of my team will be at
community board meetings. Uh, some other
familiar faces. Shelby Garner is the
chief of staff. Um, Bree Pair is going
to be doing community affairs. And um
Anna Barrett who was on uh my campaign
team is doing comms for legislation and
budget. Sophie Sakor who works with
worked with Alex Gores's office has
joined our team. So we've got an
all-star group. Um we're hiring for
constituent services. Um but we are up
and running. Uh you can email us at
district4selic.gov
which is the same email that you could
reach that and the phone number is the
same. So, we're just just a slight
difference, a different person there.
But, um, I'm really thrilled that Keith
will hopefully continue to serve in
Albany and we'll continue to have a
really strong partner and advocate for
the district. In that, we have a handout
at the back with all of our office
contact information and the names of the
team as I know many of you are just
getting to know us, at least in the
official capacity.
And I wanted to invite you all to my
inauguration which is on January 25th at
300 p.m. We are going to have the
Nickerbacher parade perform and uh we'll
say say a bit more about the vision for
the district and I couldn't be more
excited to serve. I know that the work
that's done in this room and on these
community boards is incredibly important
and neighborhoods work best when
residents are treated as true partners.
Um, I'm here to listen, to learn, and to
begin a working relationship that's
rooted in respect and follow through and
follow up.
>> Do we have time for questions?
>> Certainly. Yeah.
>> Uh, Stu had his hand up first and then I
have
Sorry.
You thought about the importance of
affordability and then you seem to
connect that to education and I wasn't
quite clear what the nexus is if you
could just elaborate on that.
>> Yeah, I think uh universal child care,
universal prek and prek as extensions of
our education system, those are such
formative years uh for for people for
children. Um, so we know that at 35 is
when a lot of that development is
happening. So having access to high
quality affordable child care before the
public school system kicks in to me is
directly tied to positive outcomes for
children and for education longer term.
Ann I think was next
>> and then Jerry.
>> Um so I I want to first thank you. Um
many of our elected officials never send
in
the reports that I assiduously read
before. So I really appreciate that
you're like two weeks in the job and you
already did it. Um, [clears throat] but
I have to say I didn't get a sense and
what I would love to hear for you is
what are your priorities and what do you
like what do you hope to accomplish and
I don't want to make it sound like a job
interview
and a half on that. I love that.
>> Of course. Uh, I had about a yearong job
interview for for this job. So not not
perturbed by the question. Um, I I grew
up in New York. I think New York is the
best city in the world. Yes. Um, and I'm
very proud of this city. Um, and I want
to fight to keep it that way. In more
recent years, um the trend hasn't hasn't
been at the same standard as the city I
grew up in, and it doesn't feel like the
New York I grew up in where people don't
feel safe on our streets, whether that's
from a wizike when you're just trying to
walk home from the grocery store or uh
shopping in CVS and there's someone who
loots or you you have to call attendant
to get your toothbrush out of CVS jail.
um to being able to practice your
religion and feel safe doing that. Um,
so public safety is a large theme and
I've also seen how our there's a huge
fight on our city with affordability
which we talked a bit about and Harvey
Aldo has emphasized as has our mayor and
it's become so expensive to live in this
city and people, friends, neighbors are
having to move out of the homes that
they've grown up in, the neighborhoods
that they've grown up in or have to move
out of the city altogether and that's
unacceptable for the for the fabric. of
our city, the diversity of our city.
That's what what makes this place so
great. Um, so we can break that issue
down further. There's housing as a large
part of that and I think it needs to be
a big part of the conversation. Um,
increasing housing supply, expanding
programs like screen and dream so that
more people apply for them who are
eligible. I think there's a big
awareness problem. Um, but also those
income thresholds are too low for the
cost of living in the city when you know
your your con Edison bill for a
two-bedroom apartment could be $1,000 a
month. So, um, addressing the um, you
know, those programs and keeping people
in homes when um, we need to be
providing services and not uprooting
families. And then um, dive into the
education, child care part of it. That's
also a very large part of the cost of
living here. Um, and utilities. So, the
council needs to step in and make help
make the city a lot more affordable. Um,
I also care about quality of life. Um, I
think quality of life has a different
definition for a lot of people, but uh,
city council is the closest layer of
government to the people. We're the ones
who will answer the phone as as Harvey
said before when you can't reach the
mayor. So, we're we're the we're
available to um help navigate difficult
civic ch like challenges that you're
having with your government, whether
that's a 311 request that has yet to be
responded to or an application where
it's taking a few months to get a
response and you need it right away. So,
our office is going to be responsive to
those types of issues and constituent
services is the bread and butter of what
a council office does. So over the next
last two weeks I'd say and for the next
couple of weeks making sure our office
is up and running that we've developed
those intergov relationships and are
delivering on constituent services and
addressing any quality of life concerns
that come through our door. And then
lastly I'll add modernizing government
as a as a personal priority of mine. We
are in a situation where state and local
is asked to be producing and doing more
with less where the federal government
is falling short. So you see cities
needing to fill that gap and um I I have
a background in tech and care about
figuring out ways that we can expand the
services that we're offering, increase
access and make it easier to work with
government. Um there an example that
affects wide is uh HPD doesn't have the
technology to detect mold um in in the
same way that the tenants association
has. They've purchased that technology.
It shouldn't be that much of a disparity
between u what the private markets are
offering and how our government is is
operating. So modernizing government. So
I've given you a lot [laughter]
but rule number one in an interview is
keep it tight. So um I'd say
constituents of services and delivering
for people affordability, public safety
and then modernizing technology.
>> Jerry had a question here.
[clears throat]
>> Howdy and welcome. It occurs to me that
what I'm going to ask everything is
logistics and to the point please
consider being a notary public after 2
p.m. I know from experience it's all
done by that point. Uh and the last two
um is there consideration of increasing
this uh uh constraint on fake AI ad
beyond the last 90 days? I don't like
the fact that they would still be in the
primaries, but let me back that. Is
there any federal constraint preventing
us from zooming the immigration
interviews? So those are my two
questions.
>> Ah interesting. So one is on AI
legislation and making
>> is currently at 90 days. What
>> I think that with any legislation you
have to start somewhere. So this will be
an ever evolving target much like the
technology which is ever evolving. So
something to keep revising and Zoom is a
great idea for addressing the issues we
were talking about before where you're
afraid to show up for an appointment.
Um, so those are both great ideas to to
bring back. I'll let you know.
[clears throat]
>> Thanks, J.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, you've got your Oops. Is off.
Anyway, you've got your plate pretty
full.
Can I uh ask you to maybe add one more
thing to your agenda? I grew up in New
York City 45 years ago. It was the
greatest city on earth. It was like
little villages to small businesses
everywhere. And what I find is that we
need to bring back mom and pop shops,
small businesses. We're losing all of
these traditional places that you would
go to get your shoes fixed, to get your
your know your your little local artist
or whatever. We've lost I mean I'm old
enough to remember the smell of fish at
the Fton Fish. You weren't born that. U
but you know it made the city what it
was and it was just it was a mixture of
artists and designers and painters and
cobblers and you know it was just a
really marvelous social fabric and I
feel that we're losing it. We're not
really helping small businesses enough.
>> I agree. Um, and I I add to that empty
storefronts left and right,
>> left and right.
>> And I think it's a huge problem uh that
I hope to work on in the council. I
already mentioned that tomorrow we
should get our assignments for u
committees and one of the committees I'm
interested in is economic development
and for small businesses. I used to work
at EDC um city government on on local
economic development and completely
agree with you the city needs to be
doing more to make it first off
affordable to run a small business here.
A lot of the things that we talked about
in this conversation like the con rate
hikes there were over 100,000 if I
remember correctly um small businesses
that are behind already on their
utilities. So, if you're adding more
burden, um it's too expensive to operate
a business here. And I also think this
is where cutting red tape could help
small businesses. Um a lot of laws are
very well-intentioned, but if you're a
small business and you're trying to keep
up with regulations, it can be very
ownorous. Um so, all things that I
definitely want to look at because I do
remember that vibrant city and agree
that's what makes New York so great.
>> Thank you.
>> Um we have one more question. Okay.
>> Hi, Virginia. Um, this is not really a
question. This is just something to put
on your radar. Um, we spoke on Sunday.
Um, so it's related to that. I'm just
going to email you and your staff about
the um the healthc care for the city
retirees. You had a presentation at last
month's and I think the office has been
getting a lot of emails. So, I wanted to
just um email you and have some you or
someone from your office come and also
kind of um give your side of or like
present your position on that. So, yeah,
just I'm going to be emailing your
office. So, just wanted to put that on
your radar. Great. Thank you. Yes. And
we will set a date to come into that
subcommittee and um talk further about
healthcare for the retirees. Uh what I
will say is that I'm relieved that uh
the mayor has said you will not force
retirees to med Medicare advantage or
what I like to call Medicare
disadvantage. Um so I'm I'm glad to see
that. Uh but more should be done to
ensure that people don't lose access to
health care that they were promised. Um,
so I firmly stand with the retirees on
that front that if you're you've been
promised healthcare plan A, you should
not be forced onto a health care plan
that is far far worse, especially when
you're on a fixed income and unable to
afford the shift in cost that will come
with that. So, we can have a a longer
conversation about that in that meeting.
And I owe you a text.
>> Well, um, thank you very much. That's um
I think that's all the questions we
have.
>> Okay. Um all right. Next we have Mackie
Bentley from Congressman Nadler's
office.
Mackie.
Okay. We're going to keep on moving
because we're a little behind here. Uh
Wendy Brennan from State Senator
Cooper's office. I just wanted to wish
people a happy new year and our report
is submitted online if you need to call
our office for any reason and we do
answer the phone too. 21249535.
Thank you.
>> Great. Thank you very much. Reports are
always um extensive. They're great
exceptional.
>> Yeah.
Thank you. And now we have Payton
Schultis from Senate um state senator
Gonzalez's office.
said, but happy to take any questions.
>> Luckily, we don't have any questions.
[laughter]
>> We'll we'll do them online. Um, next we
have Julie Roland from Assembly Member
Bores's office.
[clears throat]
>> Hey, hello everyone. I'm Julie Roland
from Alex Boris's office. Hope everyone
had a wonderful new year. We got a bunch
of events coming up. I'll try to make it
quick. First is January 22nd, Thursday,
January 22nd. We're having a state of
the district. Come here. How we did last
year, uh the assembly member's plans for
the next year, his legislative agenda,
and also come have some pizza. Um that's
going to be he'll probably make his
remarks starting at 6:30. Doors will be
open by 5. Come hang out with us. We'll
have lots of lit. help either, you know,
just hang out with me casually outside
of here. Okay, great. Um, so please stay
in the district, please come. You can
RSVP. We really hope you do. We can help
you do that if you call our office or
it's bit.ly/or26
and that is also um should be on the
report. Other events we're having couple
days later, January 26, we're working
with NIL to offer free legal services.
That could be for any of you, but also
if you know anyone who's struggling with
anything or they keep thinking, I got to
call a lawyer, call our office. We'll
make an appointment. Um, we're doing
that on January 26. All day there and
these are remote uh appointments are
available. We're also going to be
working with Nile once every single
month for the foreseeable future. So, if
you're not available on January 26, call
our office. We've got upcoming ones
every month uh for months and months out
now. And a couple week days later, we're
doing a webinar on February 3rd with the
MTA. If you or your friends, family have
questions about Omni or anything MTA
related, come to the webinar. You'll get
a chance to ask questions of them
directly. Uh one month later, we're
offering free mamog services. March
26th, my mom died breast cancer. I'm
making an appointment. All of you
should. If you know anyone, saw them,
too. I put some flyers out on that uh
table. But please um make an appointment
or encourage the women in your lives to
make an appointment. Totally free. Uh we
also are going to be having shred trucks
once a month on a Saturday starting in
March. So just put I I'll make more
announcements as we get closer, but
start collecting all your papers that
you want shredded. Uh we're going to
have those events as well. And then just
quick legislative update. Right at the
end of the year, the governor signed the
raise act. For those of you who are here
at the December meeting, Assembly Member
Boris came to talk to you about it. This
now having been passed is the most
progressive legislation in the nation
that's regulating AI. This is a huge
win. Thanks for the support in it. But
I'm really really excited to see how you
know how other states follow suit. Um
but that is big win. Wanted to share
with you with that. I'll take any
questions.
>> Yes.
>> Thanks for coming. Thanks. Um, thanks
for speaking on with the state and the
district. Is that open to, you know,
everybody that wants to go or is that
just the community board members or
>> Oh, totally open for everyone. Yeah.
Sorry, I don't know where going with
that. They don't even have to live in
the district. Okay.
>> It's interesting that they want to know
the state of our district, but yes,
anyone can come, anyone interested.
Then you register before
>> it would be great if you could RSVP also
because we have a couple days left to
decide which auditorium within the venue
we're going to use. It's all at the CUNI
graduate center on 35th and 5th. They
got they got a couple different sizes of
auditorium. So you guys will get the
right the right amount of space. We'll
also order enough pizza. Any other
questions?
>> Looks like that's it. Perfect.
>> Thank you guys so much. Thank you.
Next we have Joanna Sanchez from office
from the office of Assembly District 74.
>> Maybe not. Um, who else do we
Oh, Alexander
>> Alexander Garcia from District Attorney
Bragg's office.
>> Okay. Um,
>> is he online?
All right. Um, next is Evelyn Colado,
the from um, Controller Lavine's office.
>> Yes. Uh, good evening. Can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Yes. Um, happy new year and thank you
for uh, the opportunity to speak to you
this evening. Uh, as you know, I serve
as the Manhattan borrow director for the
city comproller. We have a new
controller, the Honorable Mark Leavine,
but I will continue to be your direct uh
contact with the office. So, uh, keep
those emails coming. I'm at e l a
comroller.nyc.gov.
Thank you.
>> Great. Thanks very much. And Marielle
Ali from um she is the director of
community affairs at our burough
president's office wants to say a few
words
around. So
from
>> good evening, community board six. Um
just wanted to follow up on what our VP
has mentioned. I'm the new director of
community affairs for the office. I'm
going to share the contact details with
you. uh Ronald will continue to be our
main point of contact, but I'm also
serve as official support and really
looking forward to getting to know all
of you and working closely with you. So
my email is Marielle Ali. So that's M A
R I E L L E A L I
hat.
I'll make sure that Sandy gets shared.
Thank you. And please reapply if you're
going to reapply.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. Has anyone signed up to speak
in the public session?
>> They have. Uh, first on the list, we
have Theo Chino, who wishes to speak on
devesting the NYPD funds allocated to UN
security during the general assembly and
having the event organized at the backup
site in Geneva, Switzerland. Uh,
uh, Mr. Chino, you have three minutes to
make your remarks, but only three. You
may begin your remarks now.
>> Thank you very much. Community board six
um happy new year. Uh I am here today to
begin the process of asking the
community board to pass a resolution
recommending several action related to
UN w
and I'm the national first secretary of
the social democrat of America 501c4
dedicated to teaching socialism. We are
the socialist faction inside the
democratic party. I have submitted my
proposal in writing in which I request
that NYPD diverse resource beyond normal
police activity around the United Nation
headquarter and that there be no street
closure during UN week. As you have
heard, our new mayor has said he will
govern as a democratic socialist. I can
affirm that he is not a socialist.
Otherwise, I would not be here talking
to you in person tonight. I would simply
have it under Mayor Mandani like me is a
leftist but his type of governance is
not socialism. It is closer to meism
associated with the French leader Jean
or the British Jeremy Corbin or the
president of Mexico Claudia Shimmer.
They belong to a broad governance
current of progressive internationalism.
I am not here to beat you apart
[clears throat] from socialism but
understanding this distinction can save
a great deal of time when trying to
understand how [clears throat] different
form of governments operate.
UN week is a nightmare for New Yorker.
The United Nation was built with a
contingency plan. A second general
assembly facility identical in function
to the one here on 42nd street is
located in Geneva and it should not be a
problem for world leader to meet there.
New York City should not be required to
indeed I would then
subsidize the international institution
at the expense of its own resident. For
that reason, I'm asking this community
board to begin a discussion and consider
proposing alternative so that the entire
tri-state area is not negatively
impacted. I send a letter to the board.
I hope they passed it. Global dependency
should not require local disruption
[clears throat] when viable alternative
exist. I am here to answer any question.
Thank you very much for your time and
your
>> thank you Mr. Chuno. Next on the
speakers list is Fred Tricosh who is a
resident manager at 3303rd Avenue and
wishes to speak on the configuration the
third avenue bike lane by his building.
Mr. Trash, are you here?
I do not see him online, nor do I see
anyone stirring here. Uh, next we'll
move on to
an Surriano, the president of 333rd
Avenue Owners Court, who wishes to speak
on the configuration of the Third Avenue
bike lane near her building. Uh, Miss
Sriano, you have three minutes to make
your remarks. You may begin now.
>> Okay. Good evening. Uh, thank you for
providing me with the opportunity to
express my concerns about the new
traffic and street organization on Third
Avenue. I am an Serrianiano, president
of the of 3303rd Avenue Owners Corp,
overseeing a 204 unit co-op. Our
residents include families with young
children, professionals, and older
adults, some with ADA, mobility, or
other challenges. I have resided at 330
for almost five decades. Over the years,
this neighborhood has experienced
numerous transformations and face
various challenges.
Ne nevertheless, none of these
developments have resulted in as much
disruption as the current modifications
to our streets and pattern uh traffic
patterns. To be efficient, I'll I'm I'm
putting everything in bullets. Number
one, these are my concerns. When the
number of uh of traffic lanes goes from
four to two, a bottleneck forms across
four at least four blocks. This leads to
persistent honking and other greater air
pollution from idling cars and affects
the peaceful and healthy enjoyment of
our homes. UN events will cause heavier
traffic and more delays than usual. With
the new lane uh new lane arrangements in
front of our building, one designated
for the extended sidewalk, a bike lane
and a third for parking. It is difficult
to hail a cab, get dropped off, unload
groceries, or assist someone in a
wheelchair. This creates a dangerous
situation, particularly for families
with young children, sick individuals,
or those with mobility challenges.
Bicycles now utilize the new bike lane
for travel in both uptown and downtown
directions. This situation poses safety
concerns for residents as it can be
difficult to observe traffic from both
directions simultaneously.
Additionally, it can be observed that
some cyclists do not adhere to traffic
laws such as exceeding uh spots,
failing to stop at at traffic signals,
or leaving the designated bike lanes.
With 204 apartments, we receive many
deliveries multiple times daily from
DHL, UPS, Amazon, Federal Express, and
UPS and USPS,
which creates more problems. Um, moving
trucks used by residents uh to move in
and move out increase traffic and when
and when parking is unavailable, double
parking for these vehicles as well as
the delivery. uh previously mentioned
creates bottlenecks by narrowing lane
lanes even further to one lane.
Due to the new street configuration and
post office trucks parking in front of
our building, we lose most of our
parking spaces. The post office trucks
also park in front of fire hydrants,
which is a safety sat uh hazard for our
residents, making it difficult for
emergency vehicles uh to access our
building.
>> Mr. Riano, your time has elapsed.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Thank you very much for your
remarks. Uh the next person on the list
is Alan Cyrunk. Uh is Alan Cyrunk here?
doesn't appear. So, uh, next person on
the list is Leonardo. Um, you didn't
give your last name, so you can give it
to us when you get up here. Uh, wishes
to speak to the board about urban
mobility and herb intelligence.
You will have three minutes to make your
remarks. You will begin your remarks
now, but please give your last name for
the record.
>> I represent this project.
[clears throat] We have created um a
intelligence layer so we understand how
legal and efficiently move in the city.
Our core AI understand signs or the
parking rules and let you know before
you park or after you park what the
rules are, when they will change and how
this affect uh New Yorkers is that in
2025 there was 1 million dollars in
tickets or parking tickets and
violations. Our software helps the city
move faster by helping the users
understand and eliminate the uncertainty
of when the rule is going to change and
uh also alerts you when um you are
already part and this helps um the
community to understand better how to
move legally and efficiently and also we
have a a layer that lets you share your
departure time. So nearby drivers can
see when you are about to departure and
they can arrive. So this facilitates the
location of or filing of a legal spot
and that's what our mission and we would
like to link and collaborate with city
officials in order to help users
understand how AI can help them
understand uh policy and rules. Thank
you so much for your time.
>> Thank you very much for those remarks.
That concludes the speakers list for
this evening.
>> Okay.
The minutes from the December 10th full
board meeting were distributed to board
members ahead of time by the board
office. Uh there is one modification
that vice chair Sarah Whittington gave
the report for the parks, landmarks, and
cultural affairs committee. If there is
no objection, we will adopt the minutes
with that modification. Board members,
if you object to adopting the minutes,
you may raise your hand.
Seeing no objections, the minutes for
the December, excuse me, 10th full board
meeting are adopted. They soon will be
available on the CB6 website. Uh chair's
report.
Uh we have a new member. We want to
welcome Samir Anador. He's starting this
evening.
Samir, do you want to stand up? And
actually, um, any anyone who is coming
to the event on um, January the 23rd
will get to meet him in a in a better
atmosphere. Samir's already said that
he's coming
>> and he's bringing his wife,
>> which is
>> Yeah, that's why I'm New York. Actually,
my wife's doing her PhD at NYU.
>> So, yeah, good to meet everyone.
>> Yeah,
>> I must say that's very brave. Sometimes
people [laughter] don't want to bring
their spouse.
right off the bat. Right off the bat,
but look forward to
>> Exactly. Um more about the uh the
>> um so in the new year we're continuing
to work on several initiatives. Um
>> how do reimagine our waterfront? We're
exploring housing opportunities with the
department of city planning. Uh which
was one of the requirements of the ULRP
that just passed.
not just passed, but um we're working
with our fellow Manhattan community
boards to document the existing housing
stock and our housing needs. And the
Spark project, which um Council Member
Maloney mentioned, is actually starting
deconstruction.
>> And it's actually really interesting
because they're going to use as much of
the material of the existing building as
they can for the new building and the
new the new site. So, it's a new
program. Um so, Oh, yes. Uh the um Can
we show that?
>> Yes.
>> Here's the invitation
to the town hall. It's actually the same
night as our executive committee, but
>> also up here.
>> Yeah. And um we'll also be working with
our council member to um for the task
force as it continues to move forward.
>> Yeah.
>> And there are hard copies in the back
for anyone who wants copies.
>> Right. And so um each of our committees
has some homework. Um we've asked each
committee to document the district needs
as they pertain to that committee and uh
it's not an easy task but I think all
the committees will be up for it. I know
the health health committee has health
and education committee has started.
They had their first meeting about this.
Um, and we're also preparing handbooks
for new members that will provide them
with the information they need to
quickly become familiar with the work
and the history of each committee. And
so that's something we're looking to
comm community committee members to
participate in.
And we're getting together on January
23rd, five tutor city to celebrate the
new year. Uh, please bring your favorite
dish and or beverage and we are taking
uh donations.
Cash is best is what we've decided,
[laughter]
but um I think um we'll work out any
other ways that people want to donate
money to.
>> What are the donations for?
>> Um beverage and food.
>> So, but I mean if if you're a great cook
and you want to cook, that's fine, too.
And then you don't need to donate. It's
really
>> How and when do the donations go? We're
giving our donations to our secretary,
our treasure. Sorry, [laughter] our new
treasure.
>> I just found out
>> because she deals with money and I don't
know.
Um so, and we'll we'll sort out some
different ways um to do that.
>> Okay.
>> But um All right. Um and it's it's also
it's a good opportunity to meet people
on the board and as we'll get to meet
our new member as well. Um, so our
district manager, Jesus Perez, will now
give a report.
>> Happy new year, everyone. Uh, I'm glad
to see you here. I'll keep it very, very
brief. Uh, since you heard earlier that
community board applications are about
to be released. Um, remember that we do
have a resource on our website that will
be helpful for you if you don't remember
whether you have to reapply uh this year
or not. In the resources for CB6 members
section of our website, just go to
resources and pick resources for CB6
members. We have a membership status uh
resource that will allow you to see uh a
list of whether you're applying this
year or reapplying next year. And since
term limits are almost upon us, we also
have a list uh for when your term limit
is. We uh keep very good records at CB6.
So the lists are correct. Um and uh so
if you need that information, you have
it there.
>> Great.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay. Our treasurer, Tanya Aras, will
now give a report.
>> Okay.
First and foremost, I can't possibly
pretend to fill in Bee's shoes. And B,
thank you so much for everything. Um, I
know I I can't live up to you, but I'm
going to make an effort to not embarrass
you. How's that?
>> Okay. According to the Crystal Report
for January 5th, 2026, CB6 is budgeted
$627,663
and 0 for the fiscal year. This includes
street fair money of $145,901.
Encumbered liquidated money is
$335,38461.
Encumbered liquidated funds are as
follows. Rent
178,71
with 0. Personal services 139,489
with 69.
Other than personal services is
17,93.92.
Unencumbered money is 292,278.39
of which 145,901
with zero cents is street fair money.
B. How'd I do? [laughter]
No comment. That's good.
Congratulations. You did wonderful.
>> Thanks be. You're the best.
>> Okay. Um, we've now arrived at our
committee reports and resolutions. Uh,
reminder that the same rules that stated
at the beginning of the meeting still
apply. Members of the public, please
note that during this section of the
meeting, we only recognize questions
from members of the board. Okay.
>> Um, so the CB6 staff emailed the digital
ballot to all members. Please click on
the link in your email. Um, select your
name from the drop-own list and select
your vote on each resolution as
presented. do not submit the ballot
until the end of the meeting or until
after all of the um resolutions that are
to be voted on have been discussed and
presented. At the end of the meeting,
please submit um your ballot and you
must vote on every resolution, otherwise
you cannot submit it. And if you plan on
abstaining, please select abstain and
remember that this will count as a
negative vote. Final vote counts will be
announced after the second roll call. If
any part of our voting procedure is
unclear, please raise your hand and we
will address your questions.
Uh first committee up is health and
education. Ruple Kakad is chair.
>> So we have two resolution. First one is
supporting Bel
um in their city and state budgets from
the elected officials.
um a lot of the uh funding they're
getting right now um the higher rates
slightly higher rates they're expiring
in March 2026. So we want that to
continue. So that's essentially what
this is asking for is for city and state
to to extend that beyond March 2026
especially since Bel is um a safety
hospital.
Uh any questions?
The second resolution is uh any
non-essential helicopter flights in
Manhattan. Um so it's basically uh um
tours that people take in helicopters
like private flights that people take uh
to and from
basically anything that's not essential
that's not uh police or any emergency
NYU organ donation or any medical
related things. Um they would ban um
them from Manhattan. So, um, yeah,
that's what the second solution is.
>> Stu has a question.
>> Please wait for the mic or they won't
hear you at home.
>> Thank you.
>> Why does the reso include the downtown?
Uh,
which is not in our district.
>> That's not in our district. Um, we are
happy to remove it. We just figure it's
>> the helicopters flying
>> in our district. They they they take off
from there.
>> Now they actually go to Westchester.
>> Yeah.
>> So there are a lot of private flights
that kind of go upstate and other places
as well. A lot of them definitely do go
to JFK. Uh but a lot of them do go more
upstate.
>> Even Hampton.
>> Yeah. Hamptons and other places. Yeah.
It's not a question, but it's just a
clarification. Um, there have been
resolutions before targeting the finan
area where that helipad is. This is to
create a stronger awareness in a case.
Um, based on the presentation I think we
had in November, um, goes into more
detail if you're curious. um this is in
support of other legislation that's
already at state level that we want to
encourage being a fine burough issue not
just with our district. So that point in
resolution is signif [clears throat]
>> I just is there still the the helport on
the west side?
>> Uh yeah there is. And why is it in the
resolution as well?
I mean it's the same issue.
>> Yeah, a lot of the the um the tours also
take off from there. So, when we have
the presentation, um, what happens is a
lot of the helicopters kind of come from
Jersey, but a lot of them also come and
they're all basically like tours, like
the skyline tour of Manhattan, and they
go all around like
>> So, should we should we add that? If
we're going to keep the financial
district, should we add the west side as
well? Is
>> that a friendly amendment?
>> Yes. Someone said there's no friendly
amendments, but
>> they're all amendments, but but could we
amend it to include that if we feel if
we feel it's appropriate to have a
>> I think part of the reason why we
downtown and not the west side is
because it's for a larger issue that
they're attacking New Jersey state
legislation and working on the west
side.
>> That's my understanding. But we
emphasize the downtown teleport in this
resolution because it targets the east
side which we are located and our
teleport as it goes to.
>> So they're also working with the west
side and Jersey
with us. So
>> did you have a question?
I actually just want to congratulate you
on both of these resos that had I felt
fairly shocking statistics
um both about the number of helicopter
crashes and the emergency room visits at
Belleview. So, uh I just want to thank
you for doing your research and
including in the residents.
>> Thank [laughter] you.
>> Thank you. So, if there's no objection,
we'll now vote on these two res. Um,
we've we've bundled, I guess. Um, so
please mark your digital ballots or you
want to
>> um and just quickly for our February
meeting, uh we're going to have a
presentation from uh Belleview uh about
substance abuse and methadone program.
We are also going to discuss the
resolution on salt school. Um, we're
also going to have a uh NYU like so
Gloria attended an NYU open house. Um,
so we're going to hear about more the
more details about that from her. Uh,
we're going to discuss the 2028
statement of district needs as well. And
I just uh I think I saw a Virginiaian's
text that uh her chief of staff will
probably be there to discuss the city
retirees
um health plan as well. So we might we
will be adding that to the agenda for
February as well.
Anything else?
>> Uh Daniel,
>> hi quick question. What was the
resolution about the salt school? What
actually was it?
>> So,
so um Salt School is a middle school. Um
it's a blue middle school that's in our
district. It's part of a it's inside an
elementary school and because of the
class size mandates and everything, they
have to relocate because the space is
needed by the elementary school. um the
parents of the school uh the children
who go to that school. One key well
number one they they um one of the
things they said was they weren't
informed by the DOE prior to them coming
um their kids to this school. So they
want to make, you know, they are asking
for these kids to complete before moving
it. And when when it does move, they
want to keep it nearby because the
school has a relationship with NYU and a
lot of uh so they want to kind of keep
it nearby when when they do move it. So
we're going to look at that.
>> Daniel, you may have missed the
presentation by one of the students from
the school.
>> I guess that was in November.
>> And the parents, too.
>> And the parents. Yeah. Yeah.
>> And um they also had been go have been
going to the youth and education meeting
last couple of months. So they also
talked about it at those committee
meetings.
>> Okay. Thank you. Next we have
transportation. Jason from chair.
>> Thank you very much. A lot of detail
resolutions tonight. Uh our first one on
supporting a uh New York State uh
Assembly Senate bill regarding uh
intelligent speed assisted devices. Uh
basically this is a bill that um would
require drivers who have repeated speed
violations to have a uh device
[clears throat] installed on their
vehicles that would limit the speed of
their vehicle so not be able to go over
the speed.
>> Any questions?
If there's no objection, we'll now vote
on the resolution. Please mark your
ballots.
>> And our next resolution is proposing
improvements to existing cross town
protected bike lanes on 26th Street,
29th Street, 38th Street, 39th Street,
52nd Street, and 55th Street. Uh we have
protected bike lanes on those cross town
streets today. Uh we are working in
conjunction with CVS uh four and five.
uh S45 uh to uh pass this resolution um
asking for improvements and expansion of
those backlings to be wider and that
should all a better
user friendly design
>> my question about
specifically not all of these these bike
lanes on the streets that are outlined
in the resolution are the same size. So
those were some things that I was just
curious if you had that information.
Also in the reposition it said like I'm
using the word study like a general term
but it sounds like you were also asking
for like prolonged study or you know to
to maintenance for these techn
the question was that the trees aren't
the same width or the same
>> they're not the same. It's not
universal. So I'm curious about the
width if you're standing by what does
that entail and then I guess part two is
in the resolution itself reference um
attention to steady or like additional
maintenance um attention.
>> Yeah. Um so I don't think we have
specific ask to what we want to happen
with designs. Uh so we ask basically for
department of transportation to take a
look at these um cross bike lanes and
come back with a proposal as to how they
can how they can widen them. Um so I
don't want to say that we have uh we
purposely don't propose a path to follow
that. We're asking for them to come back
and make a proposal to the community
board about how they can widen the bike
lane given the different um constraints
on each of those cross streets.
Gloria has a question.
>> Well, Gloria has a question, but I don't
know if it's
just want to play something on the
record since that's what we do here.
>> You know, New York City,
the curb used to belong to the people
and that was a big deal in New York that
you could step down into a curve and not
be in danger. So, I'm wondering to
myself now, since we're just expanding
and deepening bike lanes, can't we
create a curb space for people and then
put the bike lane a little farther off
the the um sidewalk?
>> Uh yeah, sure. I mean, so I think
Hispanic pedestrian space is something
that uh we we talk a lot about uh
the transportation committee. Um I don't
know about those streets specifically.
Uh but I personally would be um
generally we're talking about tightening
trains. So these side streets have as
you only so much width and uh we're
trying to make enough room for
pedestrians, for cyclists, for vehicles
moving, for parking. So there's only so
much space to go around. Um, I love the
idea of having wider sidewalks and
having less
>> or even a small curved space for humans,
>> bicycles underneath them.
>> Sure.
>> Might be possible is what I'm saying now
as I'm listening to all this because I'm
not against the bike lanes and the whole
thing. I'm just saying I think we need
to think a little bit about that New
York used to be a pedestrian city and a
curve space was the pedestrian space and
people could walk on the sidewalk
without those little scooter motorized
scooters and all that. So I think we
kind of get everything together and I
would appreciate your team.
Uh yeah, you know, I don't think it's
something that we address in this
resolution, but I think yeah, expanding
the dedication is something Yeah, we're
constantly uh looking to support and
advocating for.
>> Appreciate it. Thanks.
>> So, if there's no Oh, Brock, sorry, you
wanted to
>> So, yeah, we totally agree about more
pedestrian space and we're I think
everybody on the committee is all for
that. Um, just want to say these streets
were chosen because they've been
designated as protected bike lanes by
the Department of Transportation. You go
on Google Maps or the city bike map,
these are protected bike lanes, but in
reality, they're not. Um, you know,
cyclists will just go and then be
veering uh into traffic because they're
constantly blocked. So, we're just
saying, listen, if you're going to
designate them as protected, they should
be protected.
Great.
>> All right. If um if there's no
objection, we'll [clears throat] please
mark your digital ballot.
>> Um I have a couple things I want to talk
about. Um first off, um I just want to
acknowledge there was a serious cycle of
injury, an accident on 57, the second
day. Um and I think that's just
important this context of everything
we're talking about today and uh as we
work to try to make our roadways safer
uh and improve the design of our
streets. Um and thoughts out to that
injured cyclist. Um, I want to address
some things that were brought up on the
third Avenue bike lane. Um, first of
all, uh, we do plan to discuss the
concerns raised around uh, entry and
exit from the garage of that building
uh, in our March transportation
committee meeting. But I wanted to just
sort of respond broadly about Third
Avenue bike lane. Uh, CBD 6 has
advocated for several years uh, to ask
for a bike lane uh, and expand the
pedestrian space and the bus lane on
Third Avenue. Uh this has been something
that we've been very publicly advocating
for for a very long time. I know
personally I'm very excited to see the
project having finally come to fruition
in. Um and as a somebody who's walked
and cycled on on the corridor, I think
it's made a big improvement on on safety
and and accessibility. Um we know from
extensive data on protective bike lanes
in Manhattan that they work to improve
safety, improve safety for cyclists,
improve safety uh for vehicles and
pedestrians. Uh we uh know that uh
reactive bike lanes work great on First
Avenue and Second Avenue within our
district. Uh and there's no reason why
Third Avenue won't be a long-term
success as is all of the other protected
bike lanes in our community. And they
grow close to growing majority of bike
lanes uh in Manhattan North
uh streets. Um and lastly, effectively
this bike lane uh provides equity to uh
the use of third avenue. Previously, we
had five avenues, sorry, five lanes of
traffic on Third Avenue, but an
extensive amount of pedestrian traffic,
legless traffic, um, and trans riders
and buses on Third Avenue. And so this
new configuration, uh, is really just
creating equity. Instead of having five
lanes dedicated to just vehicles, we now
have a much more equitable split of the
uh, use of the roadway. Um, but again,
we will be discussing their concerns
about the uh, the garage on on safety
concerns. be with them in our merch
[clears throat] game. Um, and lastly, I
just wanted to acknowledge um, last week
we had a very exciting anniversary, the
one-y year anniversary of Justin Rising.
Um,
>> I was just going to ask you,
>> there was a there was a great New York
Times article that I wanted to call
attention to a couple of the points from
it. Uh, where they were evaluating how
the program has gone over the last year.
Um, and basically the data points to uh,
basically success on virtually all
metrics. So, uh, encourage everybody to
take a look at the New York Times
article, not just take my word for it,
uh, but they specifically called out
that there are, uh, on a daily basis
73,000 fewer vehicles entering the
central business district each day,
which is really substantial number. Uh,
traffic is 4.5% faster within the zone
and 2.2% faster in the area surrounding
the zone. If you'll recall, that was a
big push back around congestion that it
was going to cause traffic getting into
the zone, around the zone. that has not
come to fruition. Uh there have been
300,000 more people uh riding the subway
each day. Uh vehicle noise complaints uh
are down on 31 17% within the congestion
uh [clears throat] congestion zone. Uh
people seriously injured in vehicle
collisions down 8.6%. The only thing
that the Times article brings as
inconclusive or potentially negative is
that air quality improvements. uh there
hasn't been a the data is a bit
inconclusive on the benefits. Um so I
think everyone should take a look at the
article but I think uh they did a great
job of summarizing how the brother's
gone and uh I think exciting to see when
you're in [clears throat]
>> Daniel go ahead. It's funny, I was just
going to ask you about that because
living in Midtown sometimes it doesn't
feel like it has done much about the
traffic, but um I find that um bike
lanes are highly respected. You know,
you don't see cars parked there. There's
they're not blocking it. However, the
bus lanes continue to be blocked.
>> Yeah. And it is an absolute nightmare
trying to get up and downtown with the
bus lanes all blocked many times by
actual police cars.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, so it is I [clears throat]
find that bike lanes are always free. No
problem. But bus lanes are a problem.
What are we going to do about that,
Jason? [laughter]
>> I I'll confess the narrative that the
bike lanes are always clear.
things are actually fairly frequently
blocked and and cyclist have to access
the bike lanes to be able to divert the
roadway. Uh but I definitely agree that
there's a similar problem on the bus way
bus lanes. Um I think solution like bus
ways where we have the the roadway fully
dedicated to buses. Those are uh one way
in which we solve that problem. We have
the resolution asking for that on 31st
Street and 42nd Street. Uh we supported
it for Teen Street's uh bus way which I
think is great. Obviously you can't do
that everywhere.
>> You can't do it on the on the avenues.
>> Yeah. Um I think um some of the things
that we have also done and supported is
having offset bus lanes. So when you
don't have the bus lane right at the
curb
>> uh that helps to uh alleviate some of
that. We're also seeing um double bus
lanes in some areas city. of Madison
Avenue. We recently passed a resolution
I think
in the spring where we'll have uh two
bus lanes on the west side of Madison
Avenue north um 42nd Street I believe.
>> Uh I think it's on the west side of the
north at 34.
>> It doesn't matter.
So, uh I think there's a number of u
different ways that we attack that
problem, but I agree uh it's something
that we need to keep seeing.
>> I like the idea of having space, you
know, like the bus lane one space over.
>> Uh yeah, and uh we recently saw that
implemented on Second, much of Second
Avenue, where we didn't, it was
previously curbside, now it's the
offset. Uh I've been meaning to look at
the data since that change went in. Um
and I [clears throat] haven't but I from
my own observation I think it's made a
big difference in the coming Friday.
>> Absolutely.
>> Sorry Ann and then Jerry and then we're
moving on. [laughter]
>> So this isn't really our problem I have
to tell you since like the third avenue
bus lane is really getting used. It's
It's so great to see and I don't feel
like the Third Avenue traffic, car
traffic is going slower. Um, and like I
said, it's not really our problem. So,
we now have bus lanes on first, second,
and third avenues and none on
bike lanes on, you know, Lexington, Har,
Madison, or
>> Yeah.
[laughter]
again,
but it's sort of absurd that
>> like the east side of of the island is
so well served and the more central area
is
>> thought
We asked for a bus lane on Park Avenue
right at the [laughter]
at the last meeting.
>> Good luck.
>> Yeah. Okay. That's that's a good thing
to bring up. Okay. So, we had a resp
uh from uh uh
>> it's a redesign of Park Avenue Park.
Yeah. So, there's
>> bus stops on Park Avenue for the cross
town.
>> Uh okay. Well, anyway, we did ask
there's some plans to redesign uh Park
Avenue to redesign the medians. As we
were talking through that, we were it
came up in our our feedback uh that we'd
love to see a bus lane, potentially a
bike lane on Park Avenue. To that note,
uh there was a survey that was sent
around in our newsletter asking for
feedback about what people want to see
on Park Avenue. We encourage if you'd
like to see a bus landing there uh to
indicate that on that survey.
>> Yeah, Mine has a question.
>> Jerry
>> and Jerry, sorry. I try not I'll try to
keep it brief because I know we all want
want to leave but we had this discussion
last year about how difficult it is to
enforce a biker responsibility. One of
my concerns I have that um
[clears throat] a large population of
bikers happens to be uh delivery guys.
That rogue behavior continues
unabashedly. I'm I live right at 1
Avenue. the bikes, the motorized
scooters and even the, you know, the
non-motorized bikes, they are always
going the wrong direction. We have a lot
of seniors in my neighborhood and I see
accidents daily. So, has there been some
thought about maybe continuing this
dialogue with the DOT and trying to keep
bringing awareness about it? Because I
see the cop standing right there. The
guy gets onto the sidewalk, takes his
motorized pipe all the way through the
pedestrians, and the cop does nothing.
Doesn't even blink an eye. and you know
aren't things search aren't supposed to
be able to copy completely indifferent
just wondering if there any thoughts on
that
>> and mine just before um actually there
was discussion of this in the public
safety committee and um there I don't
know if you had the opportunity to watch
it but there was a pretty good
discussion there and that's probably
more where this would be discussed
>> I'll briefly provide my thoughts on that
um I think one of the ways in which we
combat bicycle going the wrong way is by
having uh better uh designated areas for
cyclists to go the right way. So, I
think having bike lanes on Third Avenue,
uh we're we're providing a safe
connection up town on Third Avenue,
that's uh one way we're able to combat
that. We're being in the zones that we
want the cyclists in. Uh and that helps
to curb some of the bad behavior.
>> And Jerry had a question then we're
going to move on. In its first year,
congestion pricing raised from tolling
$550 million. Now, I just wanted to add
that.
[laughter]
>> Okay, great. Thanks. Next up, we have
Stu. Oh, we have business affairs and
licensing.
>> That's fine. [laughter]
>> We've bundled everything. We're done.
>> Five items. I want to telescope this to
three items. First item, resolution of
no objection for wine beer sign license
to uh the restaurant opening on 50th
street is part of a chain that's coming
to Long Island. They observed all the
necessities in terms of the application.
We had no issue with that and I
recommend that we approve the
resolution. No objection.
I'd like the bundle B, C, and D. These
all have to do with four-year licenses
for sidewalk cafes. All of them pretty
much were within the parameters of the
DOT. We've requested a couple of minor
changes, one of them to ensure that they
do apply 100%. Now for the DOT there is
an application and the the community
board has to approve
not make no objections but approve the
applicants application to the DOT.
Again no issues in terms of uh spacing
and just a minor issue in terms of where
table is set up. So I would recommend
that we uh approve those resolutions as
well. Last one is a
um
new dispensary
for cannabis. Um
we've checked them very carefully. They
do comply with all the new the distance
rules which should have been uh work
forthcoming from the office management
in the past in terms of their location
and in terms of their application
process. They've been through this
before [clears throat] in another
location elsewhere and
um it is a commercial area commercial
street and they comply with all
necessary um
uh actions that are necessary to get the
approval.
We have no objection to that and we
would recommend that the um
[clears throat]
board approve this as well.
In terms of my report, uh we're going to
judge district needs at our next meeting
among other things. Since we had very
few applicants so far this month, we'll
have time to do that. [laughter]
>> Okay. So, if there's no objection, we'll
vote on these resolutions. Please mark
your ballot.
>> You've just jinxed yourself.
[laughter]
>> You're not gonna You're not going to
have 40.
You've just jinxed yourself.
>> Okay. Um, next up, we have public safety
and sanitation. to desert chair
that the resolution was so written that
there's no need for elaboration but
that's not my character. Um so the
resolution support uh bill is aimed at
reducing crime committed by people with
mental illness. uh if their illness is
deemed to have contributed to their
criminal conduct. This law would divert
many such defendants from incarceration
to treatment. Uh the premise which is
supported by experiences that treatment
potentially reduces the likelihood that
such people will reaffend while at the
same time it get them back on right
course in their lives. uh in Rikers in
generally uh about 50% of inmates in
state prisons and federal prisons have
some sort of mental illness. Uh the
statistics of Rikers is also about 20%,
one out of five has a serious mental
disorder. Um and we know that simply
imprisoning people doesn't typically
make them better human beings. Uh and no
[clears throat] one thinks anyone comes
out of Breakers better than they go in.
Uh state prisons, uh prisoners have a
median of five convictions on their
records. Uh so that if all we are going
to do is send people to prison and cycle
them back to the street and then cycle
them back to prison, we're not
accomplishing anything. um if we um if
we treat their mental health in issues,
we reduce um we we interrupt the cycle,
we reduce recidivism and we reduce the
crime rate. Uh there's there's um
something of a consensus behind
[clears throat]
uh diversion. Many prosecutors, judges,
defense council are all behind it. Uh
the chief judge and the chief
administrative judge in New York.
>> Use the mic, please. the chief judge and
chief administrative judge in New York
um is successively supported. Uh our own
district attorney um Al Bragg has his
own diversion program as many other um
prosecutors.
Uh I heard at the hearing for this uh
bill uh few months ago, there was a
former police officer who's now a
Republican senator who was enthusiastic
about it. Um so the reason our for our
resolution is twofold. One is simply to
support diversion and to support this
bill. Uh but the other is that while
there is a diverse backing uh behind
diversion uh and the coalition that
backed the bill worked for two years to
get buy in um from a lot of different
people, judges and prosecutors. there
are still several issues that um of
disagreement that could end up derailing
the whole bill. So we took positions on
four of those issues which seem to be
the core um of disagreement uh with the
hopes that you know by um by taking
these positions we would um we would
help inch the debate over too passive.
Uh and now I will subject myself to any
question.
>> Marty has a question first.
>> The uh resolution doesn't show
statistics in so far as uh those people
who had been in this program before have
not gone back to jail.
um the uh it it nor does it indicate the
specific crimes that would be allowable.
Mo most you know [clears throat] the uh
mental health and drug addiction causes
a great deal or most of domestic
violence and assault and muggings and
robbing of toothbrushes from CVS. Um the
um
I I I don't necessarily see how this how
this really works. My wife had
[clears throat]
uh worked for 40 years the office of
mental health at Greenmore at Manhattan
uh psych at Queens County. They cut out
hospitals
in the
80s and built more prisons. so as to put
the mental uh the individuals with
mental health problems in prisons. Um I
don't necessarily see that there will be
funding and sufficient personnel to to
[clears throat] do what they would like
to do. There isn't even enough judges
currently in in our system to handle
their load. So, you know, this is kind
of pie in the [clears throat] sky.
So um the um some of the statistics
which are buried in footnotes um Vera um
did some analysis
uh and found that uh that treatment
reduced recidivism for the population
they looked at by around 50%.
uh the bill actually expands the number
or the range of charges that a defendant
could have and still be eligible for the
program. So you're sort of extrapolating
or they're sort of extrapolating
um what the S4 will be. Obviously the
bill resolution asks [clears throat]
for um for money for funding. Uh the
bill itself does not include anything
about funding. The um the advocates for
the bill um are very direct that this
bill is not going anywhere unless it
gets budgeted
>> [clears throat]
>> um through the budgeting process before
the government. Uh and they have
specific asks. They actually ask a
certain amount for the office of court
administration, a specific amount to
fund treatment programs. Uh the off
court administration in turn would
expand the number of what are called
problem solving courts. Uh a number
exist in New York state and New York
City. Most of them are for drugs. A few
of them are for psychiatric issues. Um
so there there are specific dollars that
they're asking for. They're not bill but
the bill's not going any money. uh and
our second
second operational u clause
talks about budgeting uh and um and that
was an issue that the people who were
concerned about the bill prosecutors um
and some of the judges raised they said
it was like an unfunded mandate and
there was agreement that there would
have to be first did I miss everything
that you said
>> that's good we're okay
an an individual with mental health or
drug drug problems um
commits domestic violence regularly.
Uh
I don't know how that's going to stop.
We we only know what the data about and
and you know there will be more data
collected
with with the programs. I mean it's been
down
and successful
>> and Steve has a question and then John
>> I actually have a few comments about the
resolution. Um first kudos to the
committee for all the time and effort
they spent looking through some very
thorny and complex issues. However, I do
have a number of concerns as someone who
supports jail diversion and alternatives
restoration programs and who used to
work for one of the service providers in
the city. My first of standup point is
that the entire expansion of the
services relies on discretionary state
funding.
>> Yeah. Given that we know what's
happening with the federal budget and
how that's in fact impacting our state's
budget, there's almost zero chance that
there will be any resources available on
the services in the bill. So this may
all be moved. But going into the content
of the resolution, the opening whereas
clause presents diversion as the default
solution whenever criminal conduct can
be attributed to drug [clears throat]
use or mental disorder, which simply is
not true. Best practices in treatment
courts emphasize validated risk
assessments and careful eligibility
screening to determine what types of
individuals should be diverted into
treatment.
The last resolved clause is equally
concerning because it mandates that the
court must order a mental health
assessment. whether or not that person
is inappropriate for diversion or if the
judge would even consider it. Which
[clears throat] ties the hands of the
people in the courtroom who are best
able to determine whether a health
assessment is appropriate or not and
ignores the reality of very limited
resources of clinicians who are doing
these assessments which will have a
negative impact on everyone who is
waiting for admission into the treatment
programs. The third resolved clause is
problematic because it supports allowing
admission to treatment without a guilty
plea which raises accountability and
leverage concerns and ignores
perspectives of the victims of a crime.
Prosecutors rely on structured leverage
to ensure structured engagement uh
sustained engagement particularly for
individuals with long criminal
histories. The resolution does not
acknowledge the procedural complexity
and the delay that can result from
restarting prosecutions long after
arrest.
Best practices typically balance
incentives with clear consequences,
something that the resolution largely
omits in favor of maximizing program
enrollment. Um, the second to last
resolve clause is so also problematic
because it explicitly prohibits the
police from playing any role in a
community supervision while the
individual was participating in the
program. Evidence-based diversion models
rely on swift, certain, and proportional
responses to violations, often
coordinated among courts, supervising
officers, and treatment providers. The
resolution's [clears throat] language
suggests that monitoring is inherently
punitive rather than a public safety
tool which may lead to under enforcement
of conditions for program participation
or delayed responses to relapse or
sconding. Lastly, the DA's office, led
by Alvin Bragg, who is widely considered
to be the one of the most progressive
DAs we've ever had in Manhattan, has
voiced strong opposition to many of the
elements of this bill, including the
areas that I have already outlined. To
summarize, there are concerns regarding
availability of funding, question about
the impact on public safety, capacity,
and quality of existing treatment
resources, and a lack of attention to
best practices in diversion programming.
Therefore, I urge my fellow board
members to abstain from voting on the
resolution. This is an incredibly
complex bill, an issue that is outside
of the expertise of the community board
[clears throat] to opine with such
specific recommendations.
Thank you.
So, um, first from the expertise
portion going backwards, uh, we're
taking the expert testimony and we're
balancing it. Uh, as a community, you
sometimes have to decide what risks
you're willing to take. Um, that's not
an expert opinion. That's a that's
something that should be left to the
community to decide. Uh, and what we're
doing in this case is trying to balance
that. Um when you talk about funding
once again
if it doesn't get funded it doesn't
happen. So you know it's it's an
important program uh and the hope is
that not only will it succeed but uh if
we put fewer people in prison we're
saving huge sums of money and some of
that money could end up being spent on
mental health care. Not just for those
who are in the system but those who who
didn't get there yet. Um so funding
funding will is is a um a
a requisite for the rest of the bill. Um
the bill doesn't presume that people
will end up going into diversion. Uh
they have to have the assessment then
they go to a treatment court and a judge
decides uh if they're eligible or not.
Um, and it's not just based on the
report, but there is a risk assessment.
Um, and the assessment is done not by an
independent
uh um psychologist, but by somebody
who's actually employed by the court and
therefore trusted by the court. Um
the um I think you were monitoring by
police officers um community. Uh it was
the committee sense that uh that we have
seen lots of instances where police have
escalated tensions. Uh you have a
population here that's been arrested
that may already have awareness about
police. There are still going to be
subject to oversight in the community,
just not by police officers. And there
is an exception um if there's no one
available in the community other than
the police. Um
if I can read my handwriting
uh which I can't but um yes these are
these four issues are issues which um
which Bragg's office uh um weighed in on
and we had to balance. So we in one
instance we went with uh wear frags with
his uh his office's objections with
three others we decided that we we
wanted to go the other way. Um I
actually um um was not only one degree
and it's one uh where I didn't agree and
it's one that you raised um and if I
could read my writing I would know what
it was. Um
but um it's it's I I mean I think in the
end uh we can say this is too complex
for us. This is this is an issue that
involves experts. We're not experts and
we're not. But that's what the community
does. We look at what experts tell us
and we balance them. Um the cost. So I
think that's
[snorts] where I'm going to conclude
that
>> and John had a question here and then B
is there a hand please. Yeah, just very
briefly
Marty and Steve covered the water there,
but just a very mundane question. Who
were the co-sponsors of S4547 and
assembly lady 4869?
>> I other than Ramos, I don't remember.
Um,
>> but is this currently on the docket?
>> Well, it's it was it's going to be
reintroduced this year.
>> Okay. We don't are any of our assembly
members who state senators supportive of
this? I do not know. I'm sorry. I I
fell.
>> I just also want to make sure I read all
that. Thanks.
>> B, please go ahead.
>> So, thank you. Um, I actually have been
involved as Marty's wife has in the
field of mental illness and probably ran
one of the biggest disability programs
dealing with mental illness. I think the
resolution is idealistic and is an area
that we should really not opine on. I
think it's been an area that's struggled
throughout the years. We don't even do
well with mental illness people that are
not in the criminal system. And I think
at the time when there is no funding and
funding will even be uh shrunk in mental
health and health insurance, I will
abstain because I think this is the
wrong time for the community board to
appine on something that we have no
expertise in. Thanks Sandy.
And I'll just point out that um that uh
first of all did do analysis and they
did find that these programs have
succeeded. Uh they don't they they
haven't looked at a banded program
obviously because it doesn't exist yet
but there did validate um that there was
success in treating um people with these
mental illnesses. Uh and again if
there's no funding this doesn't go
through. what we're asking for is
funding and then the program and
remember that much of the mental um most
of these the the the benefits of clients
are on Medicare or actually the numbers
are most
>> medicaid Medicaid
>> which is what I meant Medicaid um and so
there is actually funding uh um in
through that means
>> um okay and just comment on that Sandy
Medicaid was one of the biggest programs
cut in the big beautiful bill. So you
can't even rely on the Medicaid funding.
>> Yes, totally agreed. And and I have to
say all of the issues that all of you
have raised are things that we discussed
in the several meetings that we had
about this and we really struggled with
them too. and whether we had even the
expertise or I wouldn't even say that I
think we acknowledge that we don't have
the expertise
but we also
uh understand
that we do have [clears throat] a way
a direction in which we want our
community to go.
And one of the toughest one was the um
prele guilty like what whether you have
to [clears throat]
plead guilty beforehand. It's a really
tough one because you do want to
incentivize people to stick with the
program. But there's also really good
evidence that if
it has to that motivation has to be
internal that it it doesn't succeed if
it comes
from punitive
expectations.
And so um I think we felt overall that
the uh penalties if you lose
Um, as we said in the in the
you know if you have entered a guilty
plea there could be ramifications
that are so much worse. You could lose
your house or you could lose your job or
lose your apartment. All these things
immigration status,
>> right? that it it it could make it
harder to get out of that hole. And so,
you know, on balance, we felt it was not
better. And I hope if we keep discussing
this that, you know, your your opinion
on this and your expertise is really
valuable. But that was how how how we
approached it. And every issue you
raised in is something we we discussed
at pretty extensive way.
>> Well, there's some of it but not all of
it. Like you were at the last meeting,
>> right?
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh Jerry,
>> just just [clears throat] briefly uh I
just want to indicate my support for
this understanding the complexity. I
wrote the criminal justice forum that
this is racial equity issue. Thank you.
And and now that is reminded me what my
handwriting doesn't seem to say. Uh we
also consider that um that if somebody
doesn't have to pre plea uh then they
just they drop out of the program and
they don't succeed and it has to go to
trial um something like 97 or 98% go to
plea bargain. Uh so and and those that
don't are delayed a year or two years
anyway. I mean it takes a long time to
get to one of these trials. So, the
impact sounds like it's serious, but
it's probably pretty um pretty minimal.
>> Uh Katie has her hand raised.
>> Yes. Thank you, Sandy. I looked uh up
John's question online and found that
Kristen Gonzalez and L and Liz Krueger
are co-sponsors of the bill.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you, Katie.
>> Thank you very much, Katie.
>> Welcome,
>> Gloria. And then Brock,
>> I'm on this committee and I'm really
fought within myself, especially about
issues of murder and rape and the plea
for that. But we were at ease by the
DA's office about how certain things
would not be
>> Yeah. allowable because to me you have
to be responsible for the crimes that
are that dramatic. And so I think
we're not going to decide to go to
treatment court. [laughter]
And I think this is mostly about
expanding it more to the mentally ill
because drug treatment court is a very
real thing throughout the entire state.
It's happening every day and as mental
health is such a big issue right now. In
fact, in the health and committee, we're
looking at that too. It's expanding it
to them and they really need help. And
that's where my heart is and I'm going
to count on the judges, the DA, the
prosecutors, the social work, the
psychologists, the whole system to do
their job. Thank you, Barack.
the question.
>> Okay.
>> All right. Please, let's go ahead. Um,
if there is no objection, we'll now vote
on the resolution. Please mark your
digital ballot and just we only take
questions from the committee or from the
board at this point. Okay.
>> Thanks,
All right. Sorry. Um, uh, parks,
landmarks, and cultural affairs. Sarah
Whittington, vice chair. Do you have a
report?
>> And I say happy new year to everybody
and may be happy and happy and healthy.
We have a short report. Our next meeting
is February 3rd. There's much change
since our last report and continuing the
discussion at the February meeting with
the New York City Department of States
and Recreations to plan for their plan
to reconstruct the park house on the
east side of St. Park. And that's it for
this evening. Thank you.
>> Thanks. Uh, land juice and waterfront.
Gabe Turzo.
I will I'll be sparing you all my voice
and my do the presentation.
Thank you. Very brief. Um we're
continuing to do our research on POPS
and we have a pops application coming
down the work. So we thought for that um
it's very important as we are looking at
the future of the community. With that
we're also going to be discussing um
road salting and how that impacts our
water infrastructure and our roads and a
lot of other things. Um so please come
out and
we'll
um and then we're also going to be
talking again about the face faith based
housing um pertaining to how it comes
out of housing accounts and our next
meeting on Monday January 26th
[clears throat]
>> um budget and government affairs Steve
Perez chair
>> very
We passed two resolutions at our budget
meeting on Monday. So you will see those
next month. Um and then the next month
we'll also be discussing or continuing
the conversation about open uh the open
meetings law. So, we may have we may
have a resolution on that, but we'd also
like to uh reassert the resolution that
we passed previously that we would like
the option to be able to do um Zoom to
that rather than requiring inperson
attendance. So, we're going to see if we
can take that open as as well as some
potential amendments [clears throat] to
meet law.
>> Okay, great. Housing and homelessness,
Alec Milit.
I was going to wave my report, but as
Mike mentioned, the housing and home
defense committee is going to continue
to discuss the plate based um housing
bill. Um the [clears throat] state of
the state was yesterday. We have a new
mayor. There's a lot going on in housing
in the city and the state and so we
think it's a really important issue that
we should continue to work on and
discuss. Well, thank you.
>> When's your next meeting? Uh
>> the meeting is on Tuesday. This coming
Tuesday.
>> This coming Tuesday. Correct.
Absolutely.
And just a heads up, it turns out that
faith-based housing is much more
controversial than anticipated.
>> So, I think the discussion may um be a
bit longer than we had anticipated.
>> Yeah, it's fascinating.
>> And um it sounds like we need some more
research
on the aspects of it.
Rather than have a resolution, we we
have dueling resolutions right now.
>> Resolution,
>> land versus house.
>> Yes.
>> So, we're going to try and Someone said
it's like a marriage. We're going to try
and have both sides meet in the middle
or anyway. Um, okay. If there board
members, if you have any older business
or state, please raise your hand.
Marty,
>> prior to six years ago, we used to get
elected officials coming to every
meeting, several. It was wonderful to
have the electives here that we were
able to see them and feel of their
personality rather than on Zoom. So
about six years ago, we said send your
report and then don't say anything. Uh I
I would hope that we may uh invite our
elected officials to come and face us
and give us a feel of who they are as we
had been up through [clears throat]
about six years ago. It was uh really
terrific to see them here today.
>> And my understanding is they are always
invited but they submit their reports
because they can't attend. So, we're
lucky to have
>> they used to come.
>> Uh, I guess they're worried about
overtime. I don't know.
>> Anyway, um, Jerry will now conduct the
second roll call.
>> Yes, I am starting renewing that
tradition. Starting from the
>> Yes, thank you. Yeah. David Woods,
>> Sarah Whittington,
myself,
>> James Vera,
>> Pato,
Gabe Turzo,
>> Mark Thompson,
>> present.
>> Still alive. Samir,
>> Letty Simon,
>> present.
Sandro [snorts]
and
Sandro, you submitted two ballots.
>> Yes.
>> Clearly, it's the public.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. No voter fraud at CBC.
>> Larry out.
>> Lar is out. Okay. Ann Sullivan. I guess
Larry is out.
>> Okay. Will
>> Steven
>> present Rajma
>> Kevin O'Keefe is out
Richard
>> how Alec
>> Sandy
>> oh present
>> Anton here
>> here
>> Katie
Kate Kennedy
Not here. Right. Don
>> here.
>> Paige was out
>> Robbie
is here.
>> Resurrection.
[laughter]
>> Robia.
Gloria.
Justin
>> here. Eric is out. Jason
>> present.
Barack
>> Robert.
Yeah. Maya.
>> Beatric.
>> Stewart.
>> No.
>> Jim.
>> Yes. Liz Burr.
>> Daniel.
>> Elvie.
Morton.
Neil
>> present.
>> Kyle
>> It's a wrap.
>> Okay.
Okay, now we will uh announce the votes.
Resolution 1A for health passes. Uh 37
in favor, no opposed, no extensions, but
one not entitled. Health 1B passes, 33
in favor, three opposed, one abstension,
one not entitled. Transportation 2A
passes, 37 in favor, no opposed, one
abstension.
Transportation 2B, 35 in favor, no
opposed, three abstensions. No, not
entitled. Uh, it passes. Uh, BA 3A
passes unanimously with 38 votes. 3B
also passes unanimously with 38 votes.
3C passes unanimously with 38 votes. 3D
passes unanimously with three vote 38
votes. 3E passes passes but not
unanimously. Two opposed, three
abstensions, 33 in favor.
public safety uh does pass. 21 in favor,
six opposed, 11 abstensions.
So that's that.
>> Okay,
>> back to Sandy.
[clears throat]
>> Exactly what I was supposed to say. If
there are no objections, we will adjourn
the meeting at 11:13 p.m. Thank you.